pour fait une émission de télé assez
jeune dans sa carrière pas toujours
facile de l'assumer toute sa vie ce que
prouve une fois encore l'interview de
jérémy amelin candidats de la saison 5
de star académie c'est ans après son
passage jérémy amelin est aujourd'hui
encore chanteur interviewé par france tv
l'ancien candidat est revenu sur son
aventure au château et ne garde pas un
très bon souvenir de son passage
notamment des pratiques de la production
on nous réveillait la nuit pour aller en
salle d'interview on nous disait bon tu
peux me dire ça et ce sont des choses
qu'on avait dix ans salle cs et quand
les candidats ne souhaitait pas répondre
aux questions des journalistes ou aller
dans leur sens jérémy assure que la
production employer des techniques bien
particulière il allume les lumières dans
les chambres pour que tes potes ne
puissent pas dormir et là tes potes tu
viens de te dire vas-y répond aux
questions disent qu'ils veulent alors un
ancien candidat de la star academy
ballon sur la production choqué merci
j'ai rêvé d'être avec nous aujourd'hui
pour vous expliquer alors il ya certains
chroniqueurs qui ont tenu des propos qui
vous ont déplu
on comprenne bien ce qui s'est passé on
va revoir ses propos et après je vous
lâche-t-elle j'ai du mal moi avec les
gens qui viennent cent cinquante ans
plus tard qui disent ah oui j'ai oublié
il y avait ça aujourd'hui veulent faire
du que ces gens là veulent faire du buzz
juste pour être remarqué voilà pour dire
et magali je suis là tu peux me signer
ou non mais moi je le vois vraiment
comme ça un jeu dans le sens où ils font
du buzz ils veulent être connus sur les
réseaux ils sortent tous et notamment
fait une émission aujourd'hui donc c'est
qu'ils veulent quand même se montrer
donc moi je g j'ai un profond sentiment
de dégoût pour les gens qui déboîte les
productions où les chaînes après après
coup parce que ben peut-être que il ne
correspond plus à l'émission peut-être
que ils ont besoin de faire autre chose
et dans la vie faut avancer
il fait un peu tort aussi à ce qui est
aujourd'hui la terrasse des gens nés
libres parce que j'en connais plein moi
les gens de télé réalité et c'est des
gens bien ça des gens corrects mais
c'est à cause de ce genre de personnes
là on a une image je vais faire du buzz
voilà ces deux personnes que je connais
ni d'eve ni d'adam et que je fais honte
que je que je fais on te genre de
latéralité s'te plaît
moi je fais en réalité que jean natalité
c'est des gens bien et que moi non et
que je n'accepte pas le temps qui passe
et qu'on oui eux ils ont voulu faire un
buzz en disant que je voulais faire le
buzz
là on est encore dans le soft on se
chauffe à après sa montée par mois la
blague on fait passer pour une mauvaise
personne méchante avec de mauvaises
intentions mais je suis juste leur
donner leur sang leur vie je vais
s'articule âge leur met une grosse
fessée genre à dire maintenant vous
dites pardon et vous rentrez dans votre
chambre
on a commencé là on va encore bon p
regardez vous savez pas ce que c'est que
la télé la télé que j'ai connu la
sévérité que j'ai connus vous connaissez
pas ma vie vous savez pas les choix que
j'ai fait vous savez pas ce que j'ai
vécu je cherche un mec simple avec une
équipe éducation simple qui a envie
d'avoir une vie simple qu'il juste
enrichie par une passion qui est la
musique et la scène aller plus haut
la suite en fait je me suis mais non en
fait ces gens là pendant trois minutes
on parlait de moi et m'ont déglingué à
l'antenne alors que honnêtement j'estime
valoir mieux que ça je t'ai pas mieux
que ces gens là mais mieux que ce que
leurs propos en fait j'ai un droit de
réponse
j'ai le droit de me retrouver face à eux
et leur dire moi ce que je pense d'eux
c'est le principe de touche pas à mon
poste on a toujours les versions des uns
et des autres donc je vous laisse ces
gens je voulais ces personnes mais je
vais pas taper sur vous d'office parce
que le reportage il était très mal monté
pour le reportage dit que j'ai du mal à
assumer
d'avoir fait l'émission que je balance
ce genre de choses en fait j'ai juste
une question est ce qu'une personne
c'est qu'elle est mise de quelle
émission parle des relations que dont on
a été tiré mes propos division bell
france tv slash du télé crochet et ben
très bien le dire parce qu on est sur
une émission de médias de débats de
médias cenap et ouais on peut on peut
dire ça quand même
c'est le sens de mon propos s'était dit
sûr à droite ou à gauche au milieu ça ne
change rien au fond si ça change le sens
des propos appartement comprend deux
phrases sur trente minutes d'émission ou
jeudi pendant 28 minutes jean pascal
tutu a fait la meilleure émission que
moi ou en fait je n'ai dit que du bien
je n'ai dit mais j'ai même demandé à la
prod2 bien laisser les passages où je
disais que j'étais fier de l'avoir fait
que ça avait changé ma vie que je ne
regretterai jamais je n'ai jamais
demandé à ce que mon visage soit floutée
je n'ai jamais sorti de vérité de
balancer quoi que ce soit je n'ai même
pas accuser les missions de quoi que ce
soit j'ai simplement dit un fait que
j'ai vécu c'est ma vérité elle est pas
négociable
en fait alors la personne qui à vous
après ça surtout c'est cette personne là
c'est ma gueule ici de la donne on va
voir ce que ce que vous avez vu je crois
magali le sondage elle combat la voilà
alors aujourd'hui c'est buzz à tout prix
je veux peser sur les réseaux je veux
sortir du sale comme ça et là et surtout
les infos je ne vois pas les lunettes
les lunettes voilà voilà
magali ses baguettes c'est ce qu'a dit
pour moi je moi j'ai un profond
sentiment de dégoût pour les gens qui
déboîte les productions les chaînes
après coup parce que peut-être qu'il ne
correspond plus à l'émission peut-être
qu'ils ont besoin de faire autre chose
et c'est parti la compagnie n'avait pas
cette personne
non je n'ai absolument rien contre vous
monsieur sauf après avoir vu
effectivement votre réaction qui était
hyper déplacés et je trouve que mes
propos ont été d'une violence extrême
parce qu'ici on est effectivement une
émission de médias on est là pour donner
notre avis c'est notre travail est fait
et ça quand on fait des émissions et
quand vous faites une émission vous même
il faut l'accepter parce que vous mettez
en danger
voilà moi quand je fais une émission
j'accepte les critiques par contre je
n'accepte pas les menaces voilà donc
j'accepte de vous critiquer parce que je
n'ai pas
et si vos propos et j'en ai le droit par
contre en aucun cas je vais vous et
menacé physiquement ce que vous avez
fait tout ça hyper déplacer et sa mort
non mais non mais pendant comme une
femme très bien je suis et que je ne
mériterait absolument pas qu'on me
baisse ma culotte je faisais moi parce
qu'en aucun cas monsieur personne ne
prendra et ne baissera ma culotte donc
je vous la donne et les cadeaux à
l'épreuve ai je fait très longtemps que
je voulais non ça c'est assez bas parce
que je vais vous expliquer non en fait
on va m'arrêter je ne suis pas venu la
peau est pardon pardon magali magail
ming mais il faut s'assurer de se donner
sur l'airé de jeu mais mélanie démission
si vous voulez critiquer vous avez
valable que vous n'êtes pas que l'idée
vous est peut-être dû juger laissez moi
parler de son arrivée deux secondes
parce que je suis non pas je ne
comprends pas pourquoi là parce qu'un
laissez moi mais j'ai après passionné
mais mettant les femmes quoi on page 12
je suis connu ces endroits que vous avez
parlé pendant deux minutes sur moi sans
me connaître sans même savoir du site
vous avez vu que je voulais donc on
prête pas brouiller une culotte on n'est
pas au souk
alors donc pourquoi ils circulent parce
qu'apparemment ils vous n'avez tout et
que vous avez vécu le pq magali bernheim
est une fessée oui c'est ça
c'est cette absence était d'accord qu'on
gère tout ça plus la langue française on
sait ce que c'est qu'une métaphore et ça
on sait que c'est un effet de style pour
faire du buzz ce dont on m'accuse moi
non mais c'est pas grave je suis venu
pour un droit de réponse je suis pas
venu spécialement pour un débat ou pour
faire du buzz ou pour faire de l'audimat
je suis venu pour un droit de réponse
très bien ok alors là droit de réponse
il répondait alors moi je vais juste
répondre que cette émission je n'ai
jamais dit ce dont on prétend par les
accusations qu'on me porte
jacques sur énormément la star academy
ça a changé ma vie j'en suis très fier
c'est une émission de télé qui ne sera
sûrement jamais égalée jamais et c'est
comme ça je ne regrette rien de cette
émission et je ne dirai rien de mal de
cette émission c'est un fait il ya eu
des choses que j'ai vécues dans cette
émission
aujourd'hui j'ai eu l'occasion d'en
parler dans une émission très profs qui
s'appelle étiquettes et qui y perd bien
monté ou monde et construit des clichés
cette fois ci c'était latéralité la
semaine d'après c'est sur les complexes
physiques peu importe c'est sur
différentes différentes différents
thèmes et là on me prouve dans 30
minutes d'émission me dis tiens est ce
que la télé réalité est truqué j'ai deux
solutions
là je vais soit sur le canapé de droite
pour dire oui sur le canapé de gauche
pour dire donc plains pas j'ai pas
l'entre-deux on a parfois de se mettre
entre deux bureaux ça dépend moi mon
message et c'est ce que j'ai très bien
expliqué pendant cinq minutes il suffit
de voir l'émission séquelles la
téléréalité est orienté on le sait tous
que que la télé réalité est orientée et
que par moments oui c'est une époque où
on n'était pas encore formaté on n'était
pas encore des candidates et réalité
comme ceux avec qui tu travailles qui
viennent pour faire un buzz qui sapent
dont c'est carrément un métier une
vocation
donc oui la terre a été créé des moments
d nous aider à créer des images et il
n'y a rien de mal à ça c'était juste une
autre d'autant que je vais vous dire moi
je veux dire la vérité la vérité de mon
époque et celle de star ac
évidemment qu'on oriente et autant que
possible les votes voilà dans le sens et
les arranger le plus bas oui
oui alors bonjour jérémy bonjour oui oui
alors moi j'ai vu des choses qui m'ont
pas aussi des plus alors je veux juste
dire qu'il ya pas mort d'homme en fait
on nous a parlé d'un sujet comme l'a dit
magali c'est notre boulot en fait on en
a parlé on attend on nous a demandé ce
comprendre qu'est ce qu'on pensait de ce
sujet là moi j'ai répondu que ça me
dirait je le redis ça me dérange que les
gens viennent cent cinquante ans plus
tard pour dire il s'est passé ici oui
c'est passer ça alors j'ai changé je te
coupe avant que tu te sens pas bien je
te laisser parler tellement je suis du
genre à couper la parole
bah ils ont là tu me dis juste à temps
moi j'ai répondu parce qu'on m'a posé la
question j'ai pas fini on sait
maintenant et tout à l'heure et donc la
semaine dernière quand capsat où il a
laissé dans les bayous pasquio n'est pas
les bras croisés il faut qu'il me suit
pour parler on a compris
j'essaye de dire en fait c'est que en
vrai il n'ya pas mort d'homme faut juste
redescendre un tout petit peu je pense
que que ce soit la star que ce soit je
sais pas moi même le bigdil on s'en fout
en fait donc on a juste dit des trucs
donc faut pas non plus monter et d'air
d'un truc de ouf en disant je vais leur
faire mettre leur fait de leur mettre
une fessée à leur faire ranger leur
chambre
on est bien sûr toi tu as droit de
réponse zain qui se répondent à une
question qu'on te poses par contre quand
apsa tout digéré il a simplement répondu
à une question peut-être du web peu
importe il a pas à dire ça ok et donc il
ya peut-être pas mort d'homme sauf que
depuis une semaine ma famille mes
proches se font insulter un site à cause
de vous comme quoi j'essaye de faire le
buzz mais moi arrêtez arrêtez de jouer